a recently released study says americans
are tipping less now than before the
pandemic that's according to the website
creditcards.com the number of people who
say they always tip their server at a
restaurant has gone down by four percent
in 20 since 2019. those who say they
always tip their rideshare or taxi
drivers also down by six percent now we
took to social media looking to get the
community's take on this issue and
jeremy j ford asked people here at home
what they've been seeing he joins us now
with more
[Music]
you'd think more tourists pouring into
las vegas would mean more tips and you
might be right tourists are really great
but that's not really the point
according to marcy locals have never
tipped well
she told me about how she goes out of
her way to stay closer to the tourists
and away from locals this is my job i
have to go where the money is and
speaking to this guy on the strip i can
see why you got a tip man you got a tip
it's being courteous to to whoever's
serving you it's out of respect
and they deserve it i'm not a big tipper
to be honest tourist kevin smith tells
me a good tip starts with good service
i've had some bad service the waiter or
waitress didn't smile didn't say hi
didn't check on me i didn't think there
was a dessert for a good tip there
looking through this eight news now
facebook post virtually everyone
supports tipping but there's a lot of
speculation on why the overall tip rate
is down if the service is bad then you
leave them a tip and you tell them how
to be better next time i tip something
even if it's a dollar tip something we
appreciate it jeremy j ford live local
now now if you want to weigh on the
issue we want to hear from you check us
out on facebook twitter and instagram
you can see that original post jeremy
showed you where others have weighed in
already
seven out of 10 of the most